pologne arrestations de dissidents mais
peut-être la mort d'un dialogue ouganda
les premiers secours français
parviennent avec difficulté dans les
régions sinistrées
le conflit des pêches attentes et
discussions pour sortir de l'impasse
mais un instinct mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir je reçois une dépêche une
douzaine de bâtiments de marine
nationale ont commencé à faire mouvement
dans le golfe de fos en direction du
port pétrolier dont il semblait se
préparer à dégager l'accès des crs et
des gendarmes mobiles ont pris place
autour du port une dizaine de chalutiers
de pêcheurs sont dans le chenal où selon
leurs collègues à terre il compte
maintenir le blocus tant qu'ils ne
seront pas obligés physiquement de
partir nous reviendrons aux difficultés
des pêches françaises dans un instinct
naturellement dès que nous aurons
d'autres informations mais nous
commençons nos reportages par un
document dans le monde actuel les
situations sont angoissantes ne manquent
pas l'une des plus dramatiques c'est
celle des réfugiés cambodgiens auquel
nous avons consacré de nombreuses
émissions et des reportages spéciaux
comment les enfants cambodgiens
perçoit-il le drame qu'ils ont vécu
depuis tant d'années surtout depuis 5 6
ans et l'époque des khmers rouges dans
un camp de réfugiés au cambodge et en
thaïlande
les journalistes américains ont filmé
les dessins de ces jeunes vous allez les
voir dans leur simplicité dans leur
nudité
ils sont terribles
la guerre quand on a six ou sept ans
quand l'horreur appartient au quotidien
de ce que nous nous appelons l'enfance
ses enfants témoigne aujourd'hui
réfugiés dans les camps de la frontière
thaïlandaise il raconte à leur façon ce
que fut leur cauchemar
il témoigne des exécutions plusieurs
millions de cambodgiens exterminer pour
créer un peuple nouveau c'est ça le
cauchemar
il raconte la religion banni les bonzes
expulser des pagodes arrêtés exécutés
on a demandé un enfant pourquoi il
dessinait de telles scènes et s'il les
avait vraiment vu oui at il répondu
souvent très souvent
comme ces sommes attelés à une charrue
ou comme ceci conduit au supplice quand
ils ont emmené mon père confie un petit
garçon il nous a seulement dit au revoir
il ne savait pas qu il ne nous reverrait
pas
il témoigne de l' exode aussi des
familles entières déplacer à quel prix
de la ville vers les campagnes
impossible pour ces enfants d'exorciser
le cauchemar
et pourtant quand on leur parle d'avenir
leurs desseins redevienne de vrais
dessins d'enfants mais leurs yeux eux
n'ont rien oublié
avec un en enlève depuis hier des
portraits géants de marx lénine et
staline qui ornait la place de la porte
de la paix céleste depuis les jours
régime et de la révolution culturelle en
vrai bar la réunion de l'assemblée
nationale chinoise qui sera marquée par
un vaste remaniement au sommet du parti
et de l'état la plupart des portraits de
mao ont été également en pologne
la crise s'aggrave à telle enseigne que
le comité central du parti ouvrier va se
réunir le président de la commission
gouvernementale des négociations avec
les grévistes de ce pic a nommé il ya
seulement trois jours a été remplacé et
de nombreux dissidents des verts était
hier soir notamment monsieur jacek
couronne leurs porte parole habituels
la situation empire bien depuis vie
jours maintenant dans ce que le grand
port de la baltique est bloqué par la
grève
toutefois un homme nouveau est apparu
aujourd'hui dans le conflit lesieu yaghi
elle ce qui est devenu l'interlocuteur
gouvernementale chargée d'étudier des
requêtes nous voyait le changement
d'homme pourra naturellement incarner un
changement d'attitude de l'autorité en
effet l'offre de pourparlers faite par
le nouvel envoyé de varsovie est
interprété comme un pas vers le comité
inter-cgt grève qui a interdit tout
contact séparées avec le gouvernement si
tel est le cas le problème pourrait
alors trouver un dénouement capables
d'épargner à la pologne
la déroute économique qui la guette il
faudra néanmoins attendre la réunion du
comité central du parti communiste
prévue avant dimanche
pour en savoir davantage l'église quant
à elle devrait être amené à faire
connaître son avis après la rencontre
aujourd'hui même du cardinal vie chinsky
avec l'évêque de danse en attendant les
dirigeants du corps le comité pour les
libertés en pologne demeurent détenus et
leur sort après les 48 heures du délai
légal de garde à vue donnera également
une idée de la manière dont évolue la
politique gouvernementale
enfin en marge du conflit lui-même le
brouillage par l'union soviétique des
radios britanniques et américaines
témoignent de l'embarras du grand allié
orientale de la pologne
le groupe principal des dissident
polonais c'est le corps qu elle
commettait d'autodéfense sociale est une
personnalité proche de ce comité réside
à paris monsieur alexandre smolar à
l'heure le cas où air lance un appel aux
dirigeants occidentaux leur demandant
d'user de leur influence pour faire
comprendre aux responsables polonais la
nécessité de réformes
monde monsieur ce polar a précisé m e
riglaire terre comment s'étaient
déroulées les arrestations
c'est une reconnaissance tacite de leur
importance dans le déroulement de
l'événement d'aujourd'hui les rôles est
très important dans la création de
certains groupes de militants des
ouvriers qu'on voit aujourd'hui aux
premières lignes des luttes ouvriers à
gdansk à l'arrière on les arrête aussi
parce qu'ils sont et qui suggère bien
souvent certains rêvent éducation aux
ouvriers et ce sont elles aussi qui
assure la liaison entre l'étrangère à
entre le moyen d'information étrangères
et le mouvement et les emplois on arrête
les intellectuels on n'arrête pas les
ouvriers et divise donc oui parce qu on
a perdu c'est vrai aujourd'hui on les
voit on n'arrête pas on ne bat par les
ouvriers on faisait ça en 70 à 76 les
autorités pensent qu'ils peuvent
toujours le faire avec les intellectuels
or je pense qu'ils se trompent et je
crois j'espère qu'ils le savent déjà et
que tous ces gens vont être libérés
avant le terme de 48 heures de garde à
vue
est ce que c'est la première fois qu'ils
sont arrêtés c'est pas la première fois
a couronné un de plus éminents aux
membres du corps passé six ans en prison
au cours des années 60 min été arrêté
deux fois ils passaient plus des trois
ans en prison
qu'est ce que la solution actuelle au
point où on en est peut-être autre chose
que politique
je crois que c'est vrai que politique
dans ce sens que ça appartient aux
autorités politiques de trouver une
solution acceptable pour la classe
ouvrière en pologne
mais si vous par politiques pensé que
leur évocation des droit de grève c'est
une révélation politique je dirais que
non ces indications classiques social
aussi bien que quand les ouvriers
démontent le syndicat libre est-ce que
c'est acceptable
je crois que c'est parce que c'est pas
acceptable pour le pouvoir
liquidation des syndicats officiels
c'est probablement aussi encore pas
acceptable de reconnaître juridiquement
le droit à la grève mais c'est que je
crois ce qui est possible c'est
reconnaissance de facto des syndicats
indépendants libres comme structures
parallèles aux syndicats officiels comme
d'ailleurs le comité indépendant
syndicale existait déjà au cours de ces
quatre années
en même temps ce que je crois ce qui est
possible ces transformations de plus en
plus des syndicats officiels suppression
des revendications des ouvriers
ensemble vous êtes optimiste je suis
optimiste parce que je vois les
comportements responsables aussi bien
des ouvriers mais aussi il faut le dire
jusqu'à ce dernier arrestation deux
autorités qui ne cherchait pas la
solution par la violence comme pendant
trois crises précédentes avec les
classes ouvrières alors à washington en
tout cas et pour la première fois depuis
le début de la crise sociale en pologne
le département d'état a exprimé
aujourd'hui son inquiétude devant
l'arrestation des dissidents la grave
question c'est celle ci les grèves
permettront-elles mener à une
internationalisation du conflit
hier on a démenti par tous des bruits
selon lesquels des troupes soviétiques
auraient étaient sur le point d'entrer
en pologne
mais les problèmes et remarques non sans
angoisse que cette journée du 21 nous
aujourd'hui marque un anniversaire celui
des événements de 1968 lorsque les
forces des pays du pacte de varsovie
entre est un territoire tchécoslovaque
mal ayant ce que l'on m'avait appelé le
printemps de prague d'afrique tellement
il ya 12 ans les chars des armes et des
cinq pays du pacte de varsovie rentrée
après
les tchèques assisté impuissants cette
invasion et les tchèques comprenez qu'il
ne pouvait pas qu'il n'avait pas le
droit de choisir la forme de socialisme
qui leur convenait ça a été fini du
printemps de prague
dans ces jeunes garçons comme l'ensemble
de la jeunesse dentaire jusqu'au bout de
dialoguer avec les soldats russes ils
essayèrent jusqu'au bout d'expliquer
d'expliquer que l'appartenance de la
tuque la slovaquie au poupe des pays de
l'est n'était pas en cause cette jeune à
cette population tchécoslovaque au matin
entre 21hoo 38 ne pouvait croire que le
socialisme à visage humain c'était fini
depuis les tchèques résiste passivement
et subissent une répression qui si elle
n'est pas sanglante est néanmoins
permanente nous présente notamment les
gares des signataires de la charte 77 et
avec une certaine discrétion les
autorités tchécoslovaque ont fait en
sorte que les principaux dissidents sont
autorisés à aller travailler à
l'étranger pour ensuite les prix les
contre leur gré de leur nationalité
il ya 12 ans des soldats polonais
participer à l'invasion de prades
aujourd'hui le rapport au sein du pacte
de varsovie a très nettement évolué ce
qui fait croire qu'on ne verra pas de
soldats tchécoslovaque envahir dans le
cadre du pacte de varsovie envahir la
pologne
la comparaison qui vient à l'esprit est
elle exacte varsovie 1980 peut-être
devenir la prague ou à l'inversé une
instance aux 180 total se comparer
excusez moi de le changement des dates
elle devenir le frac de 1968 c'est à
dire peut-on y voir le même événement
que ce qu'on a eu le mérite il ya 12 ou
non jouer toufik pour l'instant tout cas
rien
les dirigeants soviétiques ne manifeste
pas du tout cette espèce d'irritation
profonde qui lui restaient en outre 68
quand la pravda tous les jours tirer à
boulet rouge sur ce qu'elle appelait les
contre révolutionnaires tchécoslovaque
monsieur dirais qu'au fond n'a commis
aucun crime majeur peut reprocher à
monsieur duch est qu'il n'a pas aboli la
censure il n'a pas rendu la parole aux
opposants au contraire il n'a pas promis
la pluralité par des partis politiques
bref
l'ordre règne toujours à varsovie et le
kremlin n'a pas de raisons vraiment
foncer les chercher tout au plus
manifeste-t-il de premiers signes
d'énervement par exemple avec ce
brouillage des émissions occidentale de
radio ce qui montre que vraiment moscou
ne veut pas que les ressortissants
soviétiques sache ce qui se passe en
pologne
non monsieur y encore un peu de temps
devant lui pour négocier un peu de temps
mais pas beaucoup de temps il faut
maintenant résoudre le problème
premièrement parce que ça risque
d'entraîner une catastrophe économique
si ça continue deuxièmement pour que
monsieur direct reste crédible aux yeux
de ses amis soviétique et troisièmement
pour qu'ils restent crédibles aux yeux
des polonais peut même ne pas alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer bon
d'ailleurs cette réunion du comité
central
à la fin de la semaine on va
certainement procéder à quelques
limogeage spectaculaire pour l'exemple
on va peut-être organiser quelques
grandes manifestations de soutien au
gouvernement
et puis à partir de là la vraie
négociation va s'engager
monsieur direct valence et à ce moment
là vraiment dans la balance toute sa
force toute sa souplesse de conciliateur
qui sont considérables n'est ce pas
toute force de négociateurs est très
grande à ce moment là il faut bien dire
qu'il devra vraiment jouer son va tout
à new york halloween une réunion il ya
soir du conseil de sécurité sur la
question de jérusalem
par 14 voix et une abstention
l'abstention des états unis le conseil a
invité tous les états à ne pas
reconnaître jérusalem comme capitale de
l'état d'israël
le conseil a également demandé que
toutes les missions diplomatiques plus
retirées de la ville et cet après-midi
israël a rejeté officiellement la
décision du conseil de sécurité disant
qu'elle était à la fois injustes et
unilatérales et prouvant que l'onu le
site était devenu un instrument aux
mains de ceux qui luttent contre le
droit à l'existence est l'un des
provinces distraire la grande bretagne
s'intéresse au programme français de
développement des sur régénérateur et
elle participerait volontiers au bloc
continental formé par cinq pays
européens dans les domaines de la
recherche et de l'utilisation de cette
filière je cite là monsieur vendre east
directeur des applications industrielles
nucléaires ou commissariat à l'énergie
atomique soviétique à propulsion
nucléaire a été ravagé par un incendie
la nuit dernière vers l'océan pacifique
à 150 km à l'est de l'île d'okinawa 9
descente hommes d'équipage sont morts et
près de cinquante autres ont été
blessées indique l'agencé japonaise de
sécurité maritime alors le sous marin
soviétique que vous voyez sur les images
a refusé les propositions de secours
d'un bateau et de deux hélicoptères
japonais arrivés sur les lieux
apparemment pour protéger les secrets
militaires
les blessés ont été transbordés
aujourd'hui à bord d'un navire
soviétique arrivé à la rescousse les
experts japonais estime que l'incendié
est dû au mauvais fonctionnement des
circuits électriques
mais les avions de patrouille japonais
n'ont pas repéré de signe de fuite
radioactive par la france conflit des
pêcheries et de la mer les discussions
se déroulent de manière soutenue dans
les ports entre les représentants des
préfets et ceux des professions
maritimes
çà et là quelques incidents dans les
ports pétroliers la mise en garde lancée
hier par monsieur barreau grévistes est
au centre de ces discussions
par ailleurs à saint nazaire on commence
à s'inquiéter pour l'approvisionnement
de la raffinerie de donges et un souci
identique anime les responsables des
ports de fos-sur-mer et de retard vers
où les chenaux restés bloqués par les
grévistes
il ya seulement 40 minutes où en est on
des barques qui bloque le canal de
caronte dans les ports de fos lavéra et
l'étang de berre les chenaux d'accès aux
raffineries reste interdite certes la
paralysie n'est pas totale mais 21
pétroliers au minéralier sont toujours
immobilisé en rade du second complexe
pétrolier européen
ce matin une unité légère de la marine
nationale avait été aperçu au sud de
port de bouc
elle ferait maintenant mouvement sur le
golfe de fos ou gendarmes et crs ont
pris place sur le port bloqué par une
dizaine de chalutiers seul ce soir les
petits pêcheurs avaient accepté de
mettre fin à leur blocus et puis nous
apprenons à l'instant que l'ensemble des
remorqueurs de france cesseront travail
si la marine intervient à fos c'est une
décision de la cgt
reste qu'au plan national le conflit se
durcit après l'échec de la réunion
d'hier avec le ministre des transports
et les syndicats appellent à la
poursuite de la grève sans faille et
dans l'unité jusqu'au prochain conseil
des ministres du 27 août dit la cfdt
alors que la cgt dénonce de son côté la
sale besogne que veut faire effectuer le
premier ministre à la marine nationale
fin de citation ce n'est bien sûr par le
point des armateurs qui exige le
déblocage des ports commerciaux pour la
seule compagnie générale maritime les
pertes dues au blocus atteignent déjà
entre 4 et 6 millions de francs
à la demande du ministre des transports
la commission nationale de conciliation
pour les conflits du travail maritime se
réunira lundi prochain lundi 25 août à
paris sous la présidence de monsieur
françois icig directeur général de la
marine marchande
le premier ministre veut que la marine
nationale assure la libre circulation
dans les ports pétroliers est ce un
avertissement une menace ou
l'utilisation éventuelle d'une procédure
normale
autre question quelles sont exactement
les missions de la marine nationale dans
le domaine civil
et de quelle manière pourrait-elle
intervenir concrètement dans le conflit
actuel père m'a pas dit la marine
nationale dépend du ministère de la
défense
c'est 70 milles marins sont répartis sur
plusieurs bâtiments
les sous marins nucléaires les bâtiments
de combat porte-avions croiseur corvette
les bâtiments de transport
les remorqueurs et autres navires
auxiliaires les différentes missions de
la marine nationale
la dissuasion nucléaire tout d'abord
avec des sous marins puis la défense des
côtes des approches maritimes ce sont
des missions de guerre
enfin une large mission de service
public police de la navigation sur le
rail d'ouessant par exemple sauvegarde
des vies humaines et par conséquent
assistance aux marins pêcheurs
aidé par la marine nationale pour le
transport du courrier les soins médicaux
que ce soit à terre neuve ou parfois
moins loin pour lutter contre le blocus
des ports pétroliers il faut que la
marine nationale soit réquisitionné par
le préfet car c'est lui qui est chargé
de la sécurité du territoire national
dont le port fait partie le préfet fait
donc appel aux moyens maritimes
approprié l'action elle-même dépendra
des circonstances mais la marine
nationale n'utilisera pas ses bâtiments
de guerre de combat elle fera intervenir
des petits bateaux qui manoeuvrent
facilement qu'ils ne sont pas armés
comme les remorqueurs de haute mer ou de
navigation côtière
comment est ce que les pêcheurs
réagissent à une éventuelle intervention
de la marine nationale
jean claude renaud et l'équipe d'antenne
2 ont embarqué aujourd'hui à bord d'un
chalutier de port en bessin qui bloquent
la voie si l'europe si des bâtiments de
la marine nationale arrive
j'ai le port du havre est ce que vous
allez faire pour les attend là les en
arrachant les attend vous n'allez pas
lever le blocus en lan pas du tout et si
vous force à lever ce blocus pour la
smat a sûrement on va se battre
tout destiné à passer ce fait
on n'est pas peur qu'il y ait des dégâts
des blessés moi je pense quoi le col sud
du tibet que cinq ans 22
franche pas du tout
décidé à pour s'associer à pia regarde
plus les cargos reste dans la rade
des renforts de chalutiers sont même
arrivés aujourd'hui une cinquantaine
environ forme le barrage
le ciel s'est couvert au havre mais la
forte brise reflète mal la tempête
provoquée par les menaces d'intervention
de la marie car pour les pêcheurs après
l'échec des négociations
rien n'est réglé et ils craignent qu'une
semaine de blocus
les servi à rien
alors si la marine vous obligeait le
vélo plus l'excusé les perles de les
reprendre la mer on va voir à prendre la
mairie
saluant l'excellent choix on sera bien
obligé mais shanghai à se mettre au
courant et a posé près de toulouse
c 'est recommencèrent courrier 10 jours
et on a nos loyers payés on a tourné
comme les autres embaucher 20 heures par
jour
ah ouais prend pour la semaine
sur la vierge fidèles chalutier de 21
mètres basé à port en bessin
il y aujourd'hui le second le mécano les
trois hommes d'équipage
beaucoup de lassitude aussi est la
volonté de ne pas devenir impopulaire
ce matin vous avez laissé sortir les
plaisanciers du port du havre c'était
par souci d'apaisement
norbert ce gisement avec l'humanitaire
pour les gens on en fait moins mal
veulent un dollar
il ya deux car ferries le ventre cet
après midi
ses défauts
photo maurice pour leur âge comme pour
les quarts volé le troisième jeu compris
et vous me laisserai pas entraîner
à l'époque la solution saas avec les
marins se reconvertissent dans une autre
activité
j'ai positif était à l'étude bon et ça
c'est quinze navigateurs de tous en
vacances dans des grandes vacances
bombay samedi des combats communs
laura diablement plus je mange parler de
face au dollar ont récemment eu deux ou
trois tigreaux de et la sicile pour le
marché commun rien qu'à prendre ce
classement final des fragments d'âme on
arriverait grenade à la vérité séduire à
leur arrivée la ville quand un peu comme
étant alors là si ça continue comme ça
corollaire l'augmentation qui a eu du
gasoil de plus ajoutant même si elle
continue comme sa forme et ça c'est
vraiment les choses
j'y croyais encore l'avenir de la pêche
chez eux après avoir d'abord il ya le
mans c'est vraiment vers le port arrêter
la pêche artisanale et quelques bateaux
la pêche industrielle puis par celle
comment il travaille avec sa jument
nous devons vraiment charleroi de trop
et après toi vous avez des enfants j'en
avais trop contraignant
le ps dans une lettre au président de la
république est signé par françois
mitterrand et les élus socialistes les
régions côtières le ps donc demande
qu'on ouvre des négociations tripartites
pour résoudre le conflit des marins
pêcheurs qui a pris une ampleur
nationale
et alors que les réunions de
conciliation n'ont abouti à aucun
résultat
voilà qui pour les socialistes confirme
ce qu'ils ont dit souvent le rôle de
l'état dans le secteur des pêches et des
six il apparaît le comité central des
armateurs de france demande que la
liberté d'accès dans les ports de
commerce soit rétablie et garanties il
dénonce des actes qu'il qualifie de
piraterie et qui porte un coup sérieux à
la réputation internationale de nos
ports imposant de lourds préjudices à
d'autres secteurs de l'équipe demain 23
août pardon après demain 23 août notre
émission samedi et demie traitera du
conflit des pêcheurs quelles sont les
issues possibles
y parviendra ton et bien parmi les
invités monsieur joël le theule ministre
des transports qui sera entouré de
spécialistes
les plaisanciers et en demies
circonstances vont avoir à passer des
heures pas vrai facile alors leur
crainte c'est que le temps de se gâtent
et que la mère me deviennent grosse quel
sera le temps pour eux sur les routes
surtout laurent broomhead et puis par la
même occasion pour le week-end quand je
pense que nous pouvons être optimistes
pour le week-end même si pour l'instant
des nuages traverse le pays alors demain
et bien encore beaucoup beaucoup de
nuages le matin sur les frontières du
nord-est du jura au nord des alpes et au
nord du massif central mais ça
s'améliorera dans la journée avec photos
dans ces régions des éclaircies partout
ailleurs maintenant voyez parfois vous
voyez nuages et soleil se partagent le
ciel attend un peu instable quelques
degrés de moins que les jours précédents
mais tout de même un temps d'été
principalement sur les côtes
méditerranéennes
il faut dire que mistral et tramontane
pousseront les nuages samedi est bien le
même tableau sur l'extrême ouest plus de
soleil à un peu de brume brouillard le
matin partout ailleurs un temps encore
instable nuages et soleil est encore
quelques averses principalement dans le
nord-est du pays
et si tout va bien théoriquement
dimanche
vont être le retour du temps très beau
et j'espère show finale de la coupe
américain est ce que la france va y
participer
je dois dire que france 3 une bonne
chance puisque le bateau du baron bich
même devant la marque de bateaux anglais
par trois victoires à une
les deux bateaux dispute en ce moment ce
qui est peut-être la dernière régate si
les français l'emportent ils seront
qualifiés pour la finale des
challengeurs et s'il gagne cette finale
ils iront peut-être dans la grande
finale alors l'autre demi-finale du
challenger oppose vous noyer sur votre
écran sverige le bateau suédois
australia australia mène par deux
victoires à une
verrier malgré la protestation du bac
australia a obtenu gain de cause et la
remporter la troisième manche
aujourd'hui ces deux bateaux sont au
repos les australiens ayant obtenu une
journée de relâche appelé le led et joe
dassin est mort il avait 42 ans
il est décédé au restaurant à papeete
d'une crise cardiaque
la deuxième en quelques mois né d'un
père russe et d'une mère hongroise il
avait fait ses études en italie en
grande-bretagne en france en suisse et
aux etats unis
joe dassin aimait à dire après une
existence mouvementée
je travaillerai jusqu'à la quarantaine
et puis je m'arrêterai pour vivre enfin
mais pris dans un engrenage il a
continué à travailler et le voici qui
n'est plus 42 ans
une réussite professionnelle exemplaire
joe dassin ne laissait rien au hasard
même pas ses loisirs il pratiquer le
golf et le jogging
il prenait aussi le temps de se reposer
mais peut-être pas assez le 18 juillet
en pleine tournée une première crise
cardiaque le contraint à l'abandon à
mois après c'est la crise fatale malgré
l'intervention immédiate de deux
médecins on reconnaît d'ailleurs dans le
monde médical que l'angine de poitrine
frappe des gens de plus en plus jeunes
faut-il croire aussi que le métier du
spectacle tel qu'il est pratiqué
aujourd'hui est terriblement destructeur
avec ses tensions ses excès ses se
couche dans les villes familiale et la
nécessité de se dépasser constamment
joe dassin répondait un peu à cela quand
il parlait son exigence dans l'exercice
de sa profession
j'ai l'impression que d'avoir le droit
ou le privilège de me distraire les gens
est une chose très importante au max un
peu de gens entendent dix tracteurs
public et je considère ça un honneur et
j'ai l'impression de bonnes mérité c'est
vrai cette fois que le groupe swing je
ne lisais pas possible lors de me passer
alors je suis très embêté et c'est pour
ça que je me fais toujours une tête
comme ça j'ai l'impression que celle-ci
à quelqu'un qui quitte la salle sans
s'être amusé que je mets volets soit vis
du cinéaste jules dassin de la
violoniste béatrice launay joe dassin et
mêle aventure il avait parcouru les
etats-unis de long en large
mais il avait aussi obtenu un diplôme de
théologie à l'université de michigan
après les essais infructueux de
chanteurs en amérique 7 en france qui
s'imposa avec des chansons à succès
comme l'été indien
les dalton ou les champs elysées lui
préparer pour la rentrée une comédie
musicale
nous ne la verrons pas il nous restera
le souvenir de son sourire et la chaude
couleur de sa boîte
demain le professeur slama chef du
service de cardiologie de l'hôpital
lariboisière sera l'invité d'antenne
2010 lui et d'autres spécialistes vont
essayer d'expliquer ce qu'est cette
maladie dans leur bassin qui elle frappe
et comment l'on peut essayer de s'en
préserver
en ouganda les secours français sont
arrivés il ya déjà quelques jours à la
suite de l'effort exceptionnel décidée
par le gouvernement français et dont
entre autres serez liane la missionnaire
lumineuse vous avez expliqué ici même
l'absolue nécessité mais des difficultés
ont surgi d'ordre administratives
souvent et aussi à cause d'un certain
nombre de manques de communication voici
en édition spéciale le reportage de
philippe gassot et jean-françois rejoue
en ouganda
ce raid sur en tb pour raison
humanitaire menée par des soldats sans
armes ne va pas sans difficultés
l'opération prendra 24 heures de retard
car une plume comme on dit dans le
jargon des pilotes d'hélicoptères a été
malmené durant le transport entendez par
là qu'une pales du rotor s'est cassé il
faut que le transall aille à bangui
chercher la pièce de rechange
aujourd'hui 17 août le transall de
l'armée française d'école pour sortie
ville qui se situe dans la zone
contrôlée
plus loin au nord c'est l'inconnu les
militaires tous engagés sont pour la
plupart arrivés de paris le matin même
et n'ont eu que le temps de descendre du
boeing 707 de ligne pour monter dans le
transport de troupes
est ce que vous pouvez me dire quelles
sont les prochaines difficultés que vous
allez rencontrer là vous connaissez pas
le terrain a sorti le terrain connaît
pas du tout toute façon est notre
problème c'est d'avertir le plus tôt
possible
soro tigres qui n'ont pas eu le temps de
prévenir l'aéroport en très bon état se
trouve à 35 minutes dans tb
habituellement il faut six heures de
route
ici c'est la première étape avant le
nord et sa famille soldats qui ont vu à
la télévision les documents concernant
l'ouganda s'attendait déjà à côtoyer la
misère
cette foule venue par curiosité ne
souffre pas de la fin
l'arrivée d'un avion quels qu'ils soient
est déjà un événement mais d'un appareil
français avec des soldats à son bord
s'est vraiment l'attraction qu'il ne
faut pas manquer cette auprès de
l'aéroport que sera installée la base
opérationnelle pour l'émission dans le
nord la grosse préoccupation c'est que
je ne connais pas le pays s'est
éventuellement les problèmes de sécurité
c'était un entraînement des problèmes de
vol
j'ai beaucoup de préoccupation
actuellement et ils sont toutes
importantes davantage des hélicoptères
c'est d'éviter ces pistes où plane à
chaque kilomètre la menace d'une attaque
par les pillards les fameux riders la
dernière attaque remonte à une semaine à
mort auto il y a eu trois victimes au
cours des sept heures de piste que nous
avons parcourue de sortie à mort auto et
de moro tout acabit nous avons rencontré
à plusieurs reprises des hommes armés
sans uniforme
heureusement pacifique dans la capitale
du nord pavoiser pour des raisons
électorales la situation s'est bien
améliorée à l'endroit même où avait été
tournée de terribles images ceux qui ont
dû quitter leurs villages ne sont plus
que trois cents pour un camp qui a
compté jusqu'à trois mille personnes ce
qui en ont eu la force sont retournés
chez eux
les autres sont morts les derniers qui
restent ne bougerons pas tant que la
nourriture continuera à être distribués
grâce aux organisations internationales
la maigreur reste grande la nourriture
ne manque plus à présent toutes les
gamelles son plein et les carrats
mahjong peuvent parfois faire des
provisions
l'effort à faire maintenant et médicales
il n'y a toujours qu'un médecin
ougandais à l'hôpital à 250 mètres de ce
camp qui ne sera pas visités se tient la
réunion politique de milton obote et
ancien président qui espère bien
retrouver ses fonctions après l'élection
du 30 septembre prochain et qui assure
que tout ce qui se passe dans le pays et
dans le nord notamment va changer
monsieur le président vous êtes ici en
ouganda dans la pire région où sévit la
fin que signifie votre présence
il y à trois facteurs ici la sécheresse
la famine et l'insécurité
il n'y a rien à faire contre la
sécheresse concernant la famine j'ai
remercié expressément divers
gouvernements dans le monde qui ont
fourni une aide à l'ouganda et diverses
organisations qui ont fait la même chose
dans ces compliments sont inclus ceux
qui vont au gouvernement français non
nous avons beaucoup apprécié
l'assistance pour la sécurité il ya
quelque chose à faire que les ougandais
peuvent faire et je suis ici
premièrement pour obtenir la sécurité et
à propos de l'armée qui commet parfois
des exactions
je vais me renseigner autant que je le
peux afin de pouvoir dès mon retour à
kampala proposer des solutions au
gouvernement pour une coopération entre
l'armée et la population et établir
ainsi la sécurité dans la région
vous avez apporté de la nourriture avec
vous je n'ai pas de nourriture
je viens d'exil 9 ans d'exil je voudrais
bien avoir de la nourriture
j'ai promis à la population que si je
pouvais obtenir un camion ou un sac de
haricot n'importe quelle nourriture
elles seraient distribués dans cette
partie ci de l'ouganda milton obote et à
de la sécurité une idée toute
personnelle si avec l'armée il attend de
voir
il prétend qu'il a négocié directement
avec les chefs des raiders et que ceux
ci ont accepté la trêve avant de rendre
les armes en échange d'un statut
d'ougandais à part entière l'attaqué de
lundi dernier semble démentir ces
informations et l'armada qui entourent
le président à cathy d'eau notamment
laisse à penser que tout est loin d'être
réglé sur les pistes du nord pour le
candidat qui luttent contre l'image
d'impopularité qu'on lui a dit ils
coller sur le dos on a fait venir c'est
une tradition à plein camion toutes les
populations valides et disponibles des
environs pour fêter le leader de
l'ouganda people congrès une campagne
africaine ou au milieu de la fête on a
fait venir pour les besoins de la
télévision étrangère
les petits malheureux que l'on avait
gardé à l'écart la nourriture n'est pas
arrivé ce qui a été monté dans des
véhicules discret du convoi par
centaines de bouteilles c'est de la
bière introuvable dans la région et qui
va servir à payer les danseurs les
gardes et les supporters il est
déconseillé de filmer les bouteilles et
ceux qui boivent
pourtant même si chaque candidat prétend
que la nourriture arrive
grâce à lui la belle race d'écart à ma
jambe de ceux qui n'ont plus de vaches
et menacé à 75 kilomètres d'ici ak bong
à l'extrême nord du pays la misère à
reculer géographiquement de 150 km mais
elle est encore là et pour longtemps
cette misère s'agrippe maintenant dans
les régions inaccessibles
ici sont rassemblés les enfants trouver
chaque jour dans la brousse par les
seuls missionnaire qui s'occupe d'eux
pour ces orphelins ou pour la population
il n'y a pas de médecins pas de
médicaments peu de nourriture et dans ce
seul endroit quinze enfants meurent
chaque semaine
pourquoi parce que cabon gay loin que la
piste est trop mauvaise
qu'il ya trop de monde à nourrir dans la
région pour le peu de nourriture qui
arrive alors que dans le sud
les entrepôts sont pleins et que la
nourriture risque de se gâter la route
des candidats à la présidence ne passe
pas par ici il n'ya que les missions
qu'ils fassent l'impossible même si elle
n'y croit plus vraiment pourquoi pensez
vous qu'il peut être difficile de sauver
ces personnes nous avons dans la région
60 mille personnes si nous voulons
donner à chaque famille un kilo de
nourriture
combien de camions il nous faudrait
entre morteau et cab mieux quelle est la
solution
c'est difficile où les mêmes réponses
pensez vous qu'il est possible d'amener
des avions ou des hélicoptères s'il ya
des stocks suffisants amour auto assault
rôti et si vous avez la possibilité de
les amener jusqu'ici la plupart des gens
d'ici vont t'ils mourir à votre avis
dieu seul le sait je crois que oui j'ai
vu tellement souvent de mai et juillet
tout autour de la mission cinq ou six
personnes mourir chaque jour
que se passera-t-il pour cette région
les hélicoptères français peuvent sauver
presque tous les enfants mais le temps
presse pour aller plus vite il faudrait
peut-être que les responsables de
l'opération consulte ceux qui
connaissent les problèmes sur le terrain
on attend beaucoup de la france car la
france peu beaucoup
elle vient de mettre en oeuvre le seul
moyen efficace pour sauver les carrats
mahjong alors ce matin l'hélicoptère
français a apporté à kasugho venait de
boire les médicaments et la nourriture
nécessaire une dépêche qui me parut un
tel instant l'amiral préfet maritime de
toulon a lancé peu avant 20 heures un
ultimatum donnant aux pêcheurs dix
minutes pour qu'il dégage
la passe de fausses l'amiral a annoncé
que passé ce délai d'autres bâtiments de
la marine nationale
stationnant bang golf viendrait en
renfort des neuf unités qui sont déjà
engagés dans ce port à vincennes le
tiercé été gagné par le xiii qu'elle nie
que driver janot goujon et qui
appartient à 21 h deuxième le disque
habile 13e le 5k ternay voici les
rapports et bien pour 1 franc dans
l'ordre 2771 et dans un ordre différent
500 de 50
je vous rappelle brièvement lendemain
nuageux et quelques ondées des flandres
gauche et à la savoie ailleurs il fera
beau c'était avec l'autre qui vous
donnera les désinformations
vers 23h10 demain antenne de midi avec
patrick lecocq et les médecins que vous
expliquons les raisons de la mort de joe
dassin et la manière de lutter contre
ces sortes de maladies
et si tel est votre choix nous nous
retrouverons demain soir à 20 heures
bonne soirée merci